one of the challenges is you're
essentially an eyewitness account like
we don't have good data
we have very limited data of um of the
incident that you've experienced
so let me kind of dig in let me just ask
some questions
of uh maybe to see if there's
just to paint more and more of the
picture one you kind of mentioned so tic
tac
shape let's break apart two situations
one is the video
let's look at the actual i account the
the eyewitness account that you saw with
your own eyes
what's the what can you say about the
shape of the thing is there
interesting aspects outside of the tic
tac like is there any appendages
is there some texture to it
that no smooth white
tic tac no we don't you don't see
there's no
no wings no visible propulsion
no windows no probes that we could see
we don't notice like i said we don't see
the little things on the bottom of it
until we see the video
in the tv mode when it's zoomed in
right before it's shortly you kind of
see them zoom in you don't see it
typically on the youtube stuff that's
out there
um but remember we're looking at the
original tape so there's not there's
basically
no degradation but when you saw your
eyes there's no kind of appendages no
no what about like somebody asked a lot
of people asked
you questions so i appreciate you
spending your time here let me ask some
of them
uh did you i mean you chased it so we
flew close to it relatively speaking was
there did you feel
and you wake like any did you feel it
in any way in terms of your interaction
like aerodynamically
no nothing nothing so
uh another aspect of it there's an
interesting thing you've developed a
feel
for for objects in the air did you
feel like it was surprised by your
arrival or did it let me ask a few
questions around it so
did you did it feel like the thing was
surprised
did it feel like it wanted to be seen
almost to show off its capability did
and did it what did it feel like
relative to if you were doing a um
an air fight against uh sort of like a
i don't know a a foreign jet
so one i think it i think it knew we
were there when we showed up
it's just it's me it's kind of like an
animal if you've ever been around deer
in a field you know the deer will look
up and if it sees you and you're on the
other side of the field
it'll actually go no threat and it'll
start eating you know they don't put
their tail up because you move closer to
the deer then it goes oh it's there and
i'm going to react or i'm going to move
so as we were up high and it's down
doing whatever it was doing
um you know which i don't know someone
asked what do you think oh maybe it was
communicating with something i joked on
good morning america maybe it's like
talking to the whales kind of like star
trek you know
and they actually use that clip it's
kind of funny but yeah we're a little
human-centric
we think like it would it show up to
talk to us but maybe he's talking to the
dolphins
maybe yeah whatever you know because it
was hanging around that white water and
i don't know if was there something
there was a seamount we just didn't find
it again i don't know
but once we started the descent and it
actually reoriented its longitudinal
axis and it started mirroring us coming
up and it was obviously where we were
there and it was really coming up just
you know you figure i'm at 20 and it's
coming up and it ends up getting up to
12. uh
where i cut across the circle i think it
was very aware that we were there
because it interacted we call it a
two-circle fight when you're fighting
another airplane
um but uh you know
was it was were we afraid i don't think
so
i mean and to me it was more curious you
know the curiosity overcomes any fear
that you would have and i always felt to
be honest
if i was inside the airplane especially
as long as much time as i'd spent inside
the airplane flying and doing stuff
i felt totally it was like a safe zone
i mean i've i felt totally comfortable
inside the airplane as most pi you can't
if you're in the airplane and you feel
scared it's not the job for you you have
to feel that
because the airplane is part of you now
yes you know i am inside i have the
stick i have the throttles i've got my
whizzo in the back seat he's running all
the displays
we are a team we're in the state of the
art
airplane you know brand new you feel
pretty good
and then you get something that you know
can climb from the surface up and then
accelerate like it did like it was like
no big deal
you know for an airplane if you just put
me from a stance let's just say slow
flight just get me at 100 knots
above the water and for me to you can't
just start a climb i'd have to lower the
nose i'd have to accelerate and then i'd
have to start coming up and
this thing just like just did it like it
was like no big deal
you